i have seen every episode every minute
of top chef
and you won the whole enchilada and
i love your new show fast foodies will
you tell us about it
yes so fast foodies is equal parts
comedy
fun creativity i mean we're taking some
of the most
simple things in the entire world fast
food guilty pleasures
and we're turning them into like the
most creative
imaginative things you'll ever see so
you know strap yourselves in because it
is one heck of a fun ride
and it's all the guilty pleasures you'll
never ever stop eating because everyone
loves fast food
well let's say that my very favorite
fast food moment
in my personal history is the mcdonald's
malaya fish
[Applause]
amazing and i've got a real one
right here and one of the things that i
love
so much on your new show fast foodies is
you will imitate a classic kind of knock
it out of the park and show people how
to do it for themselves or how it can be
done
but then you also do interpretations
with your own spin um because we don't
just want imitation we want
innovation so teach me jeremy
teach me anything you want i'm all ears
yes
drew so are you ready are you ready for
this i i've never been more ready in my
life
actually i'm excited all right tell me
what to do
okay so um very simple we're gonna work
on the tartar sauce
um i want you to take the mayonnaise
the pickle relish
the capers and then i'm gonna be putting
a little bit of lemon zest
and i think by doing this you you get
like this
yes you you've used this before
i do love a zesting
and then um a little trick i like to
show
is to get no seeds in your lemon
what i do is i cut just in front of the
seeds on the side
straight down and look at that you never
have to deal with those pesky seeds
and then now just take that side i call
it like an ear of lemon
and i squeeze that ear right into our
tartar sauce and then
this will just need to be mixed a little
bit
so now that we have that done we're
gonna move on to
the fish portion of this which is super
simple
i want you to take your beautiful cod
filet
and we're gonna go straight into egg
wash
and now go to the breadcrumb give it a
little shake
yes and then make sure that you get
every little crevice with the
breadcrumbs so
pound it on the sides a little bit on
the bottom
okay so now we can drop it in the oil
very gently so once what we do now
is this will cook on each side for about
two minutes
um and then we're gonna take it out put
it on to a nice
uh towel so it can dry that excess oil
and we're just gonna put a little bit of
this thick florida cell
it's like a thick salt that i love and
it just
it looks like there's a lot of salt in
there but trust me it is like the best
salt ever
and i stand behind it these are gorgeous
i want to just
get into them right now okay okay so
now we can build our delicious
filet-o-fish that you love so dearly
okay so we take our bun bottom half
um and then we're doing like i call it
the three-quarter bin
cheese method because if you put the
full slice it's gonna like melt over the
bread and
it looks weird so i take like just like
i don't know like
15 of it and just get rid of it
let's put this on the bottom uh of the
bottom bun
just like this okay perfect
so then we're going to put our hot
crispy fish right on top of that cheese
to try to kind of get it to melt a
little bit
and then tartar sauce that you made your
fancy microplaned lemon zest
yep now the bun on top all right so now
i can bring them together
yes okay
um okay i i'm just going to be perfectly
blunt i just want to try it are we ready
cheers cheers jeremy
so lovely to cook with you
oh my god this is incredible
you know it's funny cheese and fish
typically don't go
well together for some reason this is a
magical combination
mcdonald's got it right and i
just love it this is so exciting and
everybody like get your plate get your
food
and watch fast foodies it's on true tv
it is the best show
thank you so much thank you jeremy this
was such
i love you jerome
you